Michael Kay saw it all this season
Yankees play-by-play man for the YES
Network kind enough to join us on short
rest here is they got game five coming
up tonight Mike let me ask you if I said
at the beginning of the year you would
be in this position this time of the
year what would you have said I probably
say no I think that the the aim this
year was probably just to be in it in
the wild-card in September and if you
didn't make it well it was just one baby
step and I've been saying over and over
about this team this team is about two
years I had a schedule you know they're
starting to transition younger faster a
little less expensive and then they were
going to get under the luxury tax next
year and then maybe start spending again
after that but everything's come
together and once they I think you had
to recalibrate your expectations Oh Dan
once they made those trades at the trade
deadline then they saw something in the
team they saw that judge was having a
for every year they said well let's go
for and they made those two deals and
those two deals have been pretty
important explain though what it is
about this team because I do get that
sense that feeling and you're there
every single day is it something
different about them certainly in the
postseason I think it's a really nice
mixture of youth and veterans they all
get along which is kind of rare you know
that it always seems like lip service
when they say that but they really do
get along and and strangely enough
although he's helped at the plate and in
the field when I got Todd Frazier
it became like a fun bunch of some sort
and you know it's not an act with him he
just loves being there seems like he's
been you know waiting his whole life
he's from Jersey to be on the stage and
he's having a blast and you know
everybody kind of takes his cue and has
fun with it and you know that's all well
and good it sounds like you know I wash
but they can play too they have guys
that can hit and they have a really good
bullpen and and they're starting
pitching is pretty deep so all those
things came together and and maybe they
have that it that we can't put our
finger on but they seem to to really
rise up to the big moment when the
postseason started I said the best
bullpen is gonna win the World Series
and they still believe that now I think
the Yankees bullpen is great starting
pitching has been underrated in this
series but the Dodgers bullpen might be
the best in baseball you know
gets to the to the seventh eighth ninth
inning confidence level seems to
skyrocket with the Yankees is that the
best part of this lineup the team is the
bullpen well I think it was probably in
the lead of the important parts of the
team and I think it's the big difference
between these two teams and you mean no
matter how great Keiko pitches today is
he gonna go 9 because if he doesn't go 9
they're gonna have to go into that
bullpen and you can see that AJ Hinch
really step slightly before he goes to
that bullpen doesn't seem like he trusts
anybody and two times in this series
he's he's asked his closer to get six
outs and this time he couldn't do it he
couldn't even get out of the 8th inning
so I'm gonna be very interested to see
if they have a lead late what they're
gonna do usually in this day and age the
old Yankees used to say okay let's build
up the starters pitch count and get to
the bullpen well that doesn't work that
much these days because most bullpens
are great but now I think they're going
back to what they did in the past let's
work the count let's get into the
bullpen the underbelly is not that
strong boy the Yankees really attacked
them yesterday I mean they're they're
down for nothing yeah and the
seventh-inning stretch and it didn't
even seem like they were out of it
Yankees play-by-play voice for the YES
Network Michael Kaye joining us
I like an Erin judge to Shack the shack
of baseball B you know he's he's not
just a big guy he's an athletic big guy
and nimble can you compare him to
anybody you've seen before certainly not
in baseball I just haven't seen it in
baseball with you know you've seen big
guys like Dave Kingman and that sort of
Richie Sexson but the combination of a
bath lenox skill he can run the bases
although he didn't do that well
yesterday he should really play the
outfield he has a really good arm and
obviously the 52 home runs speak for
themselves and then the thing that
really jumps out at you there two wins
away from going to the World Series and
they really haven't had prime Aaron
judge in this postseason and it wasn't
until yesterday that Gary Sanchez really
had a really really big hit so they've
done this without their two main
offensive cogs so if they found it
yesterday they all of a sudden become a
really really scary team the rest of the
way do you think Girardi was managing
for his job that wild card game
I don't know if he was managing for his
job then he might have been managing for
his job after he messed up in Game two
of the ALDS I some still not sure dammit
he'll come back on his own volition you
know he might just be done ten years of
Yankee managers a long time but I think
it would also be very tough to walk away
from the team that has this much young
talent and a lot more to come I mean
imagine being this good maybe getting to
the World Series and your farm system is
one of the best in baseball the futures
very bright so you would think that
somebody would want to manage this team
and collect some World Series rings and
maybe go to the Hall of Fame but I think
after Game two when he didn't challenge
that that hit by pitch and then the
crowd booed him you know no organization
wants to see their manager hate it and
then all of a sudden they're knocked out
so maybe there he might have been
managing for it but I know that
Palestine burner really likes Joe a lot
so it would take a lot to get you fired
Michael thank you for joining us have
fun later on today we appreciate your
time as always
anytime Dan thank you so much that's
Michael K does the Yankee play-by-play
for the YES Network the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience